[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je dis 3 janvier
bienvenue dans le 7-8 journal de tv 78
tout de suite les titres de cette
édition
depuis 1er janvier le chesnay rocancourt
ne font plus qu'un hier se tenait le
conseil d'installation de cette commune
nouvelle avec l'élection de ses
représentants philippe brillault été
désigné maire du chesnay rocancourt il
est notre invité en tout ce sont trois
communes nouvelles qui ont vu le jour
cette année dans les yvelines 14 en
ile-de-france comment fonctionnent ces
entités
pourquoi sont elles crient et quels
changements concrets apporte-t-elle
décryptage et revivre l'histoire du
château de rambouillet au travers des
contes traditionnels c'est ce que
propose le site yvelinois en cette
période des vacances scolaires
charles perrault ou encore jeanne marie
leprince de beaumont sont notamment
mises à l'honneur
ce chiffre pour commencer 1,46 million
plus exactement un million quatre cent
cinquante 8275 c'est le nombre
divinement au 1er janvier selon l'insee
sur cinq ans la population du
département a progressé à 20,2 pour cent
et versailles reste de loin la ville la
plus peuplée 87000 315 habitants
en ce qui concerne les villes de saint
quentin en yvelines montigny le
bretonneux et 7e trappe 8e et plaisir
est 10e à chaque fois au dessus de la
barre des trente mille habitants c'est
fait le chesnay et rocquencourt ce sont
officiellement dit oui les élus des deux
communes se sont réunis ce mercredi 2
janvier landes à 1 lors d'un conseil est
d'installation extraordinaire le
rendez-vous avait notamment pour
objectif de définir le nouveau maire et
ses adjoints bonsoir philippe brillault
bonsoir vous êtes donc vous étiez
l'ancien maire du chesnay vous êtes
désormais depuis hier l'édile de la
commune du chesnay rocancourt cette
commune nouvelle vous propose tout de
suite de regarder ce sujet de mickaël
millero le chesnais et rocquencourt sont
officiellement mariés après plusieurs
mois de délibérations les deux communes
ont officiellement
fusionner lors d'un conseil
d'installation programmée ce mercredi 2
janvier au schéma
la fusion est taillé un acte d'avenir un
acteur de l acte logique dans la mesure
où la fusion permettra de réaliser des
choses que nous ne tuons pas en mesure
de faire jusqu'à présent de réaliser des
économies d'échelle et puis de gouverner
avec beaucoup plus de d'aisance et de
facilité de rendre un maximum de
services à la population
lors de ce conseil dix sept adjoints ont
été nommés jean-françois peu bris ancien
maire de rocancourt a notamment été
désigné premier adjoint de la ville pour
le poste de maire l'ancien élu du chéné
philippe brillault seul candidat prend
la tête de cette nouvelle commune
baptisée le chine et rocquencourt
il a obtenu 48 voix sur 57 après un vote
à bulletin secret moi c'est la première
fois que je suis amené à gérer une
commune toute nouvelle qui a que
quelques heures
donc cela nous a appris avec
l'administration
beaucoup de choses beaucoup de l'égalité
et beaucoup de réinitialisation de la
commune
en bref une bonne remise en cause de
tout le monde ça fait du bien et ça va
rebooster nos deux communes
prochaine étape pour la vie nouvelle du
chéné rocancourt définir le nom de ses
33 mille habitants la décision devrait
être prise à la fin du mois de janvier
lors d'un prochain conseil municipal
philippe brillault est ce qu'on peut
parler de mariage de raison c'était
inévitable de faire cette fusion avec
rocancourt alors tout d'abord je veux
dire que le maire n'a pas été désigné
mais est lui élu 1 c'est important et en
fait ce qui va changer c'est les
périmètres des compétences de chacun
c'est à dire qu'on va mutualiser
je pense qu'une fusion aujourd'hui ne
peut être profitable aux habitants que
si on fait des économies sans diminuer
la qualité des services
alors pour expliquer vous a dit à une
mutualisation il y aura deux communes
déléguées au sein de cette commune au
vel que sont le chesnay rocancourt alors
un des arrondissements alors on n'est
pas obligé de faire des communes
déléguées d'accord si nous l'avons fait
c'est parce que rocancourt souhaitait
garder une identité
donc il était légitime que rocancourt
qui était entre
il met la petite commune en nombre
d'habitants mais en surface plus
importante que le chesnay puisse
conserver son identité sa culture c'est
pour ça qu'on a accepté le principe
d'une commune délégué la commune délégué
dépend complètement malgré tout de la
commune nouvelle
c'est bien la commune nouvelle du
chesnay rocancourt qui existera avec la
fiscalité d'euros concours la fiscalité
du chesnay jusqu'à la fin du mandat puis
après un certain nombre d'années on peut
avoir une harmonisation des fiscalités
c'est à dire principalement la fameuse
taxe d'habitation qui représente
allez on va dire entre un petit quart
des recettes de la commune
mais ça ça va se faire dans le temps
alors il ya des avantages budgétaires
notamment
c'est cette commune nouvelle va
suspendra grâce à cette commune aux
ailes il ya une suspension de l'amande
de l'état sur les logements sociaux
s'est alors pas l'amande la pénalité
assez manière que nous avons eu l'année
dernière pour le ch nerfs au concours
une un coup de matraque supplémentaires
mans pôle jeunesse a représenté 2 100 %
de plus à payer de pénalités ce qui
avait entraîné pour nous une
augmentation de la taxe d'habitation
parce que entre temps une baisse de la
dotation globale de fonctionnement des
baisses des deux autres donc ça veut
dire qu'à un moment l'équation pourrait
plus être tenu et aux concours sir
concours a accepté d'accélérer la fusion
c'est parce que les petites communes
peuvent être en 2019 en rupture de
paiement et c'est peut-être ce qui a
poussé vous parler de mariage de raison
la raison du moyens matériels en est une
mais il y avait aussi d'autres raisons
c'est que tout simplement naturellement
les communes vivent côte-à-côte peuvent
envisager une mutualisation est une
union au travers la fusion et cette
commune nouvelle va compter compte
désormais 31 1334 habitants environ 29
milles du chesnay 3000 de rocquencourt
officielle à qui ça profite cette fusion
est ce que c'est plus aux habitants de
rocquencourt plus aux habitants du
chesnay
les habitants de rocquencourt vont
pouvoir bénéficier de services de
d'équipement qu'il n'avait pas valeur de
démographie lui des partenaires oui nos
deux communes au concours a augmenté le
chesnay abc d'accord alors que la
moyenne d'âge de rocancourt est plus âgé
que celle du chesnay
ça montre que la disponibilité des
terrains permet de construire pour
rajeunir et je pense que la nouvelle
commune va plus rajeunir avec les
terrains de rocquencourt qu'avec les
terrains du chesnay et les phénomènes de
société montrent que la densité
d'habitants par mètre carré a b c le
nombre d'enfants de familles les
modifications familiale fonds et le
vieillissement des populations font que
le turn-over d'un logement est beaucoup
plus long ce qui explique que le chesnay
a baissé en habitant au concours un peu
augmenté et que ensemble nous avons pour
objectif de pouvoir effectivement
apporter du logement pour apporter aussi
à d'autres habitants la qualité que nous
avons dans notre commune restez avec
nous pour la suite de cet entretien en
attendant on accueille nicolas
dandrimont soir concert grégory au 1er
janvier 2019 ce sont donc trois communes
nouvelles qui ont vu le jour dans les
yvelines le chèche le chesnay rocancourt
pardon saint germain les fusionne avec
four que tout comme les communes de port
vilaine et de jeu fosse dans le nord du
département devenu notre dame de la mer
nicolas vous allez nous expliquer
quelles conséquences et quels
changements impliquent pour les
habitants applique ces communes aux
belles déjà qu est ce qu une commune
nouvelle
et bien grégory une commune nouvelle
c'est la fusion entre deux ou plusieurs
communes pour former au final une seule
et même collectivité
ce dispositif a été créé par la loi du
16 décembre 2010 modifié en 2015 et en
2016 pour inciter les communes notamment
au niveau financier
objectif affiché philippe brillault l'a
dit réaliser des économies ou lutter
contre le phénomène de communes isolées
notamment dans les zones rurales
et comme en a décidé la création d'une
commune nouvelle et bien vous avez
plusieurs possibilités défini par la loi
les conseils municipaux des communes
concernées peuvent en faire la demande
le projet peut être formulée au minimum
par les deux tiers des conseils
municipaux des communes membres d'une
intercommunalité
il ya aussi la possibilité d'un
établissement public de coopération
intercommunale comme les communautés de
communes ou les communautés
d'agglomération qui peuvent demander la
création d'une commune nouvelle qui
remplacerait les communes membres de ces
intercommunalités et dernière
possibilité c'est à l'initiative du
préfet et quels changements impliquent 7
c'est comme une nouvelle alors
concrètement philippe brillault vous en
avait déjà parlé
les municipales
et peuvent mutualiser leurs compétences
comme les tarifs des services publics
les polices municipales ou encore le
service technique c'est des choix qui se
font en fait au conseil municipal de la
commune nouvelle
au niveau budgétaire une harmonisation
fiscale progressive peut être mises en
place c'est à dire que il y aurait un
rapprochement des taux d'imposition qui
se ferait progressivement et si on prend
l'exemple du chesnay rocancourt en 2018
le ch est né il y avait chez né il y
avait un taux de taxe d'habitation qui
était de 12% à rocquencourt il dépassait
les 6 % on voit un écart de six points
contre les deux anciennes communes alors
philippe brillault comment ça va se
passer concrètement pour la commune
nouvelle il ya on voit qu'il ya un écart
quand même entre les deux avaient parlé
de pourcentage qui s'activent à qui se
positionne sur les valeurs locatives
les valeurs locatives de rocquencourt
concours étant beaucoup plus jeune que
le chesnay ya des valeurs locatives plus
forte
donc il faut bien garder le pourcentage
par rapport aux valeurs locatives ce qui
est certain c'est que notre objectif est
de pouvoir vous l'avez souligné apporter
des compétences supplémentaires à
rocquencourt sur la sécurité sur les
moyens d'urbanisme ou autre et les deux
se rapprochant on doit essayer je dirait
l'autre objectif pour mars 2020 c'est de
montrer qu en 14 mois
la fusion à apporter un bénéfice aux
habitants des deux communes tant au
niveau financier qu'au niveau prestation
c'est ça le challenge et je pense que la
fusion est un excellent outil pour
répondre à la tente du gouvernement et
de l'état c'est à dire de diminuer nos
dépenses publiques
moi je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de trop
de couche sur le millefeuille bien
évidemment et qu'il faut qu'on s'attaque
vraiment au sujet les intercoms moi je
trouve ont été décevantes
ce sont des gros mammouth qui passent
beaucoup de temps pour faire des ordures
ménagères voir différentes choses je
crois qu'entre les départements les
intercoms la fusion était un bon outil
les communautés de communes pour le
monde rural une bonne outils les
métropoles tout ça voilà je pense que
dans les mois qui viennent
on est tous demandeurs je pense d'avoir
une clarification de la finance nous
avons baissé les calibres îlot désolé
nicolas gaudois on arrive à la fin de
cet entretien dans paris avant de vous
laisser on va pas avoir le temps
d'écouter leurs interviews
les des opposants des élus d'opposition
du chéné ont déposé un recours contre
cette commune nouvelle disant qu'il ya
un vice de fondre dans la procédure
est ce que c'est une procédure qui vous
inquiète est-ce que ça avant les
conseils sur chaque délibération et
déposer recours
donc ils font partie de ceux qui
alimentent le plus de tribunal
illustratif
c'est pas une nouveauté c'est pour une
tradition mais j'ai pas l'impression
forcément que tout ça débouche toujours
sur ce qu'ils attendent
je suis tout à fait confiant sur ce qui
a été fait avec l'aide des services
attractifs de la commune des deux
communes et des services de l'état par
le biais la préfecture donc j'ai toute
confiance dans ce que nous avons pu
faire et sur ce dossier de la commune
nouvelle pour être complet il restera à
déterminer le nom des habitants les
habitants du célèbre concours et ça sera
à déterminer mais les structures se dit
déjà en avant première on s'oriente
plutôt vers les chaînes est pour toi
très bien merci courtoise bien sûr bien
sûr merci philippe brillault d'avoir été
avec nous un maire de la commune
nouvelle du chéné rococo à merci
également à vous attendre à mon collègue
jean-françois pommery qui est votre
premier adjoint dans cette commune
nouvelles merci à vous nicolas pour
votre décryptage avant de refermer ce
journal en cette période de vacances les
sites heavy noah se parent de leurs plus
beaux atouts et vous font découvrir leur
histoire au château de rambouillet c'est
au travers des contes traditionnels
chants de perrault et bien sûr mises à
l'honneur tout comme jeanne marie
leprince de beaumont les récits continue
jusqu'à la fin des vacances mais quel
ennemi d'euros et mélanie police je suis
la comtesse de mars et je suis la
gouvernante du petit enfant du château
de rambouillet celui qui s'appelle louis
jean marie de bourbon penthièvre si
rambouillet nous était conté au château
pendant les fêtes direction le xviiie
siècle
la conteuse émerveille petits et grands
dès l'âge de 4 5 ans on reste dans un
lieu historique et j'aime alliés
l'histoire la vraie l'histoire de france
et en même temps les petites histoires
amusantes pour que ces lieux ne soit pas
juste des lieux d'histoire un peu
poussiéreux mais que ce soit vraiment d
endroit vivant la tradition le mot clé
de ce rendez-vous annuel du monument
rambolitains avec château des comtes le
public renoue avec l'histoire loin de
certaines superproduction quand on va
toujours mettre en avant
la morale des fables le fait que les
comptes étaient utilisés à l'époque pour
apprendre des choses aux enfants mais
finalement s'il ya bien des vacances et
un moment où on va beaucoup plus
privilégié la féerie est juste le
plaisir d'être en famille d'écouté des
choses un peu merveilleuse et de
profiter d'un tel cadre c'est noël un
roi
c'est magnifique je me régale j'espère
autant que les enfants et j'aime bien
c'est drôle je vais j'aime surtout les
histoire
déjà j'aime beaucoup les pièces les
peintures et j'aime aussi bien les
histoires
si charles perrault et bien sûr l'auteur
phare en cette période de fêtes jeanne
marie leprince de beaumont moteur de la
belle et la bête et jean de la fontaine
ne sont pas oubliés un moment familial à
partager pour prolonger encore un peu
ces fêtes de fin d'année vous là c'est
la fin de ce journal belle soirée avec
tv 78
[Musique]